This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立适应力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些苦难，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字 TWO。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看当年》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难行易》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何其他地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《知难行易》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. The older we get, the less fun we have. That is how it seems to go, or that is the narrative that I think society would like to tell us. our 20s are often presented as this like last decade for the kind of uninhibited joy and playfulness
大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析我们20多岁的心理。我们年龄越大，乐趣就越少。事情似乎就是这样发展的，或者说这就是我认为社会希望灌输给我们的叙事。我们的20多岁通常被呈现为这样一种最后的十年，充满了无拘无束的快乐、嬉戏
and recklessness that is very reminiscent of our childhood and our teen years. But once we kind of start getting up there, all of that is apparently meant to stop. Our life revolves around work and commitments, financial and family obligations, and that kind of slice of the pie that is devoted to personal freedom and playfulness is meant to get smaller and smaller. Here's what I believe. I think that we and the world in general do not appreciate the value of play way into adulthood.
和鲁莽，这非常让人联想到我们的童年和青少年时期。但一旦我们开始步入社会，这一切显然都该停止了。我们的生活围绕着工作和承诺、经济和家庭义务展开，而那部分属于个人自由和玩乐的蛋糕切片变得越来越小。这就是我的信念。我认为我们以及整个世界在很大程度上都没有意识到玩乐对成年生活的价值。
We do not really prioritize space in our life to be unproductively social, to just hang out and be silly, to be adventurous and imaginative because there is so much that takes up our focus. And I think that is why a lot of us seem to feel like the older we get, the less joy there is in life. We're losing this sense of wonder. We're losing out on something vital. Despite that, there are so many proven benefits of play. Stronger relationships,
我们并没有真正把生活中的空间留出来，去做一些没有生产力的社交，只是闲逛、犯傻，去冒险和发挥想象力，因为有太多事情占据了我们的注意力。我想这就是为什么我们很多人似乎觉得年龄越大，生活中的快乐就越少。我们正在失去这种惊叹感。我们正在失去某些至关重要的东西。尽管如此，玩乐已被证明有诸多好处。更强大的关系，
better friendships, reduced stress, greater creativity, better overall happiness. So today, I want to really present to you my argument for bringing back playdates for adults. When we were kids and we would like have our parents call around to our friends' houses and, you know, schedule an afternoon together and the hours would, you know, swim past. It was so delightful. And it was so fun to just literally spend hours not doing much, but doing it with somebody else. And we all know that's harder now. We don't hang out like we used to. There are a lot of factors to blame. Technology is always the first culprit, but also just how busy we are, the time constraints and the societal beliefs about what it means to be an adult. We are meant to be serious and we're meant to be mature.
更好的友谊，减轻压力，更高的创造力，更好的整体幸福感。所以今天，我真的很想向大家提出我的论点：为成年人找回“玩伴日”。当我们还是孩子的时候，我们会让父母给朋友家里打电话，你知道的，安排一个下午聚在一起，时间会，你知道的，飞逝而过。那是多么令人愉快。 буквально 只是花几个小时不做太多事情，但这是和另一个人一起做的，这太有趣了。我们都知道现在这更难了。我们不像以前那样经常一起闲逛了。有很多因素需要怪罪。技术永远是第一个罪魁祸首，但还有我们有多忙，时间限制以及关于成年意味着什么的社会观念。我们应该表现得严肃，我们应该表现得成熟。
And that kind of creates a lot of psychological restraints as well, like the fear of judgment or guilt and the conditioned behavior that comes along with that to be more mature and responsible and professional. But today, we are going to break down what psychology has to say about the value of play. How important it is to have unstructured moments where you just hang out with others, even when we feel silly about doing it, why we might be missing out and how we can actually bring back this spark and this energy into our lives. We are also going to talk about concepts like parallel play, play personalities, extroversion, introversion, ambversion, and so much more. I cannot tell you how excited I am for this episode. I feel like so many of us already know
而这也会产生很多心理上的束缚，比如对评判或内疚的恐惧，以及随之而来的条件反射行为，即变得更加成熟、负责任和专业。但今天，我们将剖析心理学对玩乐价值的看法。拥有非结构化的时刻是多么重要，你可以和别人一起闲逛，即使我们觉得这样做很傻，为什么我们可能会错失良机，以及我们实际上如何将这种火花和能量带回我们的生活中。我们还将讨论平行玩乐、玩乐个性、外向、内向、两栖性格等等概念。我无法告诉你我对这一期节目有多么兴奋。我觉得我们中的很多人已经知道了
this to be true. We are craving more in-person opportunities for connection. We're craving more ways to really disconnect from reality for a little while and just like get back to that childhood wonder and awe and joy and enjoyment. And hopefully this persuades you even more so, convinces you even more so that this is something that you need to implement in your own life. So without further ado, let's talk about what I believe are all the highly compelling reasons why we should be bringing back adult play dates. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
这是真的。我们渴望更多面对面建立联系的机会。我们渴望更多真正暂时脱离现实，回归童年的惊奇、敬畏、喜悦和享受的方式。希望这能说服你更多，更深信这是你需要在自己的生活当中去践行的事。废话不多说，让我们来聊聊我所认为的所有极具说服力的理由，为什么我们应该带回成年人的玩伴日。2%。这就是有扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 T-W-O-Persent，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of... crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为……可卡因。我随时准备在某天谈论可卡因，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难行易》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这里活着的时候做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我，基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《知难行易》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索“学习困难的方式”并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律战的序幕，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕郡的突发新闻
as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. As always, let's start super simple here. Let's start from the beginning. Why do we actually need play?
劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。一如既往，让我们从超级简单的事情开始。让我们从头开始。我们为什么真的需要玩乐？
When we kind of think about our hierarchy of needs as human beings, things like food and water, safety, belonging, community, love, money, they all seem fairly obvious. Play less so. especially as adults, play really falls off of our list of essentials, even our list of extras or luxuries. For children, we understand it's a bit more valuable. Play is actually quite essential to how children learn those fine and gross motor skills. They learn how to socialize and collaborate, develop their imagination and abstract thinking. You kind of get the picture.
当我们思考人类的需求层次时，诸如食物和水、安全、归属感、社群、爱、金钱等事情似乎都相当显而易见。玩乐则不那么明显。尤其是作为成年人，玩乐确实从我们的必需品清单中跌落了，甚至跌出了我们的额外项目或奢侈品清单。对于儿童，我们知道它的价值更高一些。玩乐对于儿童学习那些精细和大肌肉运动技能实际上是相当重要的。他们学习如何社交和合作，发展他们的想象力和抽象思维。你大概能理解了。
There were some really fascinating papers and articles written in the late 90s and early 2000s that suggested that play deprivation or play deficiency, children who were not allowed to play freely as children, perhaps grow up to have less empathy, more difficulty forming social bonds. How did they discover this? They looked at mass shooters and people who were incarcerated and people who had done jail time and they compared their level of free play as children to a separate sample of people who hadn't done shell time. and what they found was one of the differences was this capacity to be play for,
90年代末和2000年代初写的一些非常迷人的论文和文章表明，玩乐剥夺或玩乐不足，即那些在童年时期不被允许自由玩乐的孩子，长大后可能会表现出较少的同理心，在建立社交纽带方面有更多的困难。他们是如何发现这一点的？他们研究了大规模枪击犯、被监禁的人以及服过刑的人，并将他们童年时期的自由玩乐水平与没有服过刑的另一组样本进行了比较。他们发现其中一个区别就是这种有玩乐精神的能力，
and this capacity to be free as children. Obviously, there were a ton of other factors associated with that as well, but the presence or absence of play and the quality of play, particularly in childhood development, does have proven long-term impacts on our emotional intelligence, our resilience, even things like brain size. There is even more evidence showing us that parts of our body, brains that are most developed in those early years between like 18 months to eight years
以及在童年时期能够自由自在的这种能力。显然，还有大量其他相关因素与此有关，但玩乐的存在与否以及玩乐的质量，特别是在儿童发展过程中，对我们的情商、韧性甚至大脑大小等都有着已被证实的长期影响。还有更多的证据表明，我们身体的某些部分，即在18个月到8岁之间的早期发展最成熟的大脑部分，
are the ones that respond best to the kind of active experience induced by being playful. It's all about the neural connections that play builds through problem solving and creating and imagining and also cooperating that makes it so valuable. But does that end when we turn 18? You know, have we done, has play kind of done all that it can for us? Those neural systems are in place now. It's time to get serious. We don't need it anymore.
它们是对通过玩耍带来的那种主动经验诱导反应最好的部分。这一切都关乎玩耍通过解决问题、创造、想象以及合作所建立的神经连接，这使得它如此珍贵。但这在我们年满18岁时就结束了吗？你知道的，玩耍是不是已经为我们做完了它能做的一切？那些神经系统现在已经到位了。是时候变得严肃了。我们不再需要它了。
You know, it's done what it's good for. Obviously, I don't think so. Absolutely not. Play is not just frivolous and it's not just for kids. It's something that is an inherent part of our human nature, probably even our animal nature as well. It might seem like a waste of time or unproductive, but there was this really a fascinating New York Times article that put it this way.
你知道的，它已经完成了它的使命。显然，我不这么认为。绝对不是。玩乐不仅仅是轻浮的，它也不仅仅属于儿童。它是我们人性中固有的一部分，可能甚至也是我们动物性的一部分。它可能看起来像是在浪费时间或没有生产力，但《纽约时报》有一篇非常引人入胜的文章是这样说的：
that is the whole point. That is the whole point of play is that it is silly and unproductive and a quote unquote waste of time. Play is a way of deliberately bringing about joy without that joy being attached to some specific goal or requirement. It is just like fun for the sake of fun. Whereas so much about our adult lives is goal or outcome orientated. You know, we ride our bikes because we want to lose weight. We go to Pilates class to get in shape. We do work trivia to maintain social connections. We cook simply to feed ourselves.
这才是重点。玩乐的全部意义就在于它是愚蠢的、没有生产力的，且所谓的“浪费时间”。玩乐是一种故意带来快乐的方式，而这种快乐并不附属于任何特定的目标或要求。它就像纯粹为了好玩而好玩。然而我们成年生活的很大一部分都是以目标或结果为导向的。你知道的，我们骑自行车是因为我们想减肥。我们去上普拉提课是为了塑形。我们做工作琐事是为了维持社交联系。我们做饭纯粹是为了养活自己。
Everything that perhaps used to bring us joy as children or even as teenagers becomes something that is part of a broader goal and kind of part of a broader structure and routine. But when we are doing things like playing Frisbee in the Park or, I don't know, mermaids in the pool or charades with our friends, even video games, we're kind of step. back from the structure of our daily lives. And it's within those daily lives that we often are kind of forced to follow a set of rules or forced to need to be taking something off of our to do-lis. When we give ourselves those opportunities to take a step back, to enjoy the moment,
我们在童年甚至青少年时期可能给我们带来快乐的一切，都变成了一个更广泛目标的一部分，并且成为了更广阔结构和常规的一部分。但当我们做一些事情，比如在公园里玩飞盘，或者，我不知道，在泳池里扮美人鱼，和朋友玩猜字游戏，甚至是玩电子游戏时，我们实际上是退出了日常生活结构的束缚。正是在这些日常生活中，我们常常被迫遵循一套规则，或者被迫需要从待办事项列表中勾掉某项任务。当我们给自己这些机会退后一步，去享受当下，
to be silly, we're channeling this in a child version of us that still exists and we're bringing them to the surface. And with that, we're bringing a sense of wonder and a new excitement to things. We're kind of turning off the stress tap, I would say, for just a second, being present. And of course, when playtime involves a friend, the benefits just skyrocket. So that's why the adult play date needs to make a comeback. And by adult play date, I mean times where we go to each other's houses or the park or the beach with the attention of creating and doing something unsurious and inherently enjoyable like art like scrapbooking lego board games make believe playing tiggy hide and seek powerpoint nights i see that on ticot all the time and i'm going to say i'm
去犯傻，我们是在引导我们内心那个依然存在的儿童版本，并将他们带到表面。随之而来的是，我们为事物带来了一种惊叹感和新的兴奋感。可以说，我们关闭了压力水龙头仅仅一秒钟，活在当下。当然，当玩乐时间涉及到朋友时，益处就会呈指数级飙升。这就是为什么成年人的玩伴日需要卷土重来。我所说的成年人玩伴日，是指我们去彼此家里、公园或海滩，目的是创造和做一些不那么严肃且本质上令人愉快的事情，比如艺术、剪贴簿、乐高、桌游、过家家、玩捉迷藏、捉人游戏、PPT之夜，我在 TikTok 上经常看到这个，而且我要说，我是一个把这作为我生活一部分的人，再次感觉像个孩子有种非常甜蜜的感觉。这是极大改善我心理健康的怪异事情之一，能够像个孩子一样。和你的朋友在一起，感觉既怀旧又满足。当我还在堪培拉生活时，作为一个成年人，我和一群朋友每周都会玩一次沙丁鱼游戏。如果你不知道这个游戏，就是一个人去藏起来，然后其他人必须找到他们并像沙丁鱼一样挤在他们旁边。这就像捉迷藏的反面。那些时刻是如此欢乐，它们是如此珍贵的记忆。现在，我喜欢通过和男友一起做乐高之类的事情来融入其中。
somebody who adopts this as part of my life and there is something so sweet about feeling like a kid again And it is one of those weird things that have greatly improved my mental health, getting to be childish. With your friends, it feels equally nostalgic and fulfilling. When I was still living in Canberra, well into being an adult, me and a group of friends used to have a weekly game of sardines. And if you don't know this game, it's where one player goes and hides and all the others have to find them and like sardine up to them. It's like the opposite of hide and seek. And those moments are so joyous and they are such treasured memories. And nowadays, I like to incorporate it through doing things like Lego with my boyfriend.
比如我们最近做了一个办公室乐高套装。当我告诉你时，我们在咯咯笑，我们太专注了，我们非常享受。我连一秒钟都没有想过工作。我连一秒钟都没有想过生活。而我们能有这种感觉的情况太少了。最重要的是，我认为成年人的玩伴日需要卷土重来的原因，是因为在这个十年里友谊变得更加困难。并且有大量证据表明，非结构化的时间正是我们改善关系所真正需要的。因为当它是一个高度结构化的
Like we recently did an office Lego set. And when I tell you, we were giggling, we were so focused, we were enjoying it so much. I did not think about work. I did not think about life for even a second. And there are so few circumstances where we get that. feeling. On top of that, the reason why I think adult play dates need to make a comeback is because friendships become even harder during this decade. And there's a lot of evidence that unstructured time is what we actually need to improve our relationships. Because when it's such a structured
活动，当它是一个高度结构化的聚会，比如我们要去吃晚餐，我们必须聊两个小时，而这将是我社交的时间。我们仍然觉得自己需要表现得“在线”。但当聚会是非结构化的时候，已被证明能够创造更深层次的联系，更深层次的纽带。它还确保我们年龄越大，就会有越多的共同记忆，我们可以像怀念童年记忆那样真正地去回忆。责任感会减少，我认为这是我们所有人都需要的。而且它的努力更少，因为有一个我们共同进行的联合活动。并且它通常比喝酒吃晚餐更便宜。
activity, when it's such a structured hangout, like we are going to dinner and we have to talk for two hours and I'm going to be, that's my time to be social. We're still feeling like we need to be on. But when the hangout is unstructured, it has been proven to create a deeper connection, a deeper bond. It also ensures that we have more shared memories the older we get, ones that we can really reminisce on the same way that we tend to be nostalgic for our childhood memories. There's less sense of obligation, which I think we all need. And it's just less effort because there is this joint activity that we're doing together. And it's typically cheaper than having drinks and dinner.
你知道，那可能每人花费60美元、70美元。但我也认为，在维持我们的社交生活方面，我们可以做得更好，而不是每两周去一次拥挤、嘈杂、灯光昏暗的餐厅坐上两个小时，并认为这会帮我们维持一种关系。有大量证据表明，作为一个代际群体和一个社会，我们需要这个，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候。当我们进入20多岁，特别是20多岁中期时，会出现一种发展和社会转变，我认为我们突然进入了那些不再促进毫不费力地社交的环境，特别是生活篇章。它变得非常刻意、限制性、时间紧迫。而那些
You know, that can cost like $60 a person, $70. a person. But I also think that we can do a bit better in maintaining our social lives than sitting in a busy, loud, too dark restaurant for two hours once a fortnight and thinking that that is going to help us maintain a relationship. There is a lot of evidence that as a generation and as a society, we need that, especially in our 20s. There's this developmental and social shift that occurs when we hit our 20s, I think our mid-20s in particular, where we suddenly enter environments and specifically, I think, a life chapter that no longer promotes being effortlessly social. It becomes very deliberate, restrictive, time constrained. And the things
限制这一切的因素就是责任。而责任给我们的有限心理资源施加了压力，这意味着我们很忙，我们筋疲力尽，我们经常感到压力重重。如果你想想你还是个青少年的时候，比如在夏天、放学后或周末到处疯跑，你没有钱，你没有朝九晚五的工作，你最大的担心就是你的家庭作业。你必须充分利用你手头的一切。所以你更有创意，你可能也获得了很多乐趣。这不仅仅是因为我们更年轻。这也是在历史上那个没有发明无所不在的技术的时代之前，我所指的是，当然，我们的手机。你知道吗？我才不会坐在这里把所有的责任都推给技术，因为我实际上认为它带来了很多好处。但这也意味着我们可以用发短信、互相发送 TikTok 以及在沙发上互动来取代面对面的互动。
that are restraining that is responsibilities. And the responsibilities put pressure on our limited mental resources, meaning that we are busy, we are burnt out, we're often stressed. If you think about when you were a teenager, like running around during the summer or after school or on the weekends and you had no money, you didn't have a 9 to 5, your biggest worry was your homework. You kind of had to make the most of what you had. So you were more creative and you probably had a lot more fun. It wasn't just that we were younger. It was also that time in history before the invention of such an omnipresent technology and what I'm referring to is, of course, our phones. And you know what? I am not going to be somebody who sits here and puts all the blame on technology because I actually think it's had a lot of benefits. But it has also meant that we can swap face-to-face interactions with, you know, texting and sending each other TikToks and interacting from our couches.
我们只是在一起的时间少了很多。我们看到，自2000年代末以来，这种下降确实开始迅速加速。我们不再经常见到人们，人们相聚的时刻往往在更多你知道的结构化环境中，比如学校或工作场所。那么我们怎么知道这一点的呢？通过一个非常酷的资源，叫做美国时间使用调查。所以这是对美国普通人如何度过时间的一个深入衡量。因此，ATUS（进行该调查的机构）的经济学家们基本上仔细追踪了花在社交上的时间，这意味着我们花在面对面互动上的时间。他们跨越了十几个不同的人口统计学指标进行了这项调查，
We just spend a lot less time together. And we've seen that since the late 2000s, that is when the decline really rapidly started to take off. we aren't seeing people as much anymore and the times when people do see each other is in more you know structured environments like school or the workplace so how do we actually know this well through this really cool resource called the american time use survey so this is an in-depth measure of how the average american spends their time so economists at the atus which is where the survey is conducted, they basically carefully track time spent socialising, meaning the time that we spend having face-to-face interactions. And they do that across more than a dozen demographics,
来自巨大样本量的多个不同领域。他们年复一年发现的是，大体上，真实世界的社交对于所有性别、所有年龄、所有族裔、所有收入、所有教育水平都在下降。当然，比如，我们需要考虑新冠肺炎疫情的影响，但我们从来没有从那段孤立时期中恢复过来。而走向孤立的趋势甚至早于大流行病。我觉得我不需要列举为什么这如此令人担忧，对吧？但是，你知道的，更多的孤独，更多的压力，更多的孤立，更多的心理健康问题。
multiple different areas from a huge sample size. And what they've found year after year is that broadly, real world socializing has declined for all genders, all ages, all ethnicities, all incomes, all education levels. And definitely, like, something that we need to take account for is COVID-19, but we never bounced back from that period of isolation. And the trend towards isolation predates the pandemic. I feel like I don't need to list off why this is so concerning, right? But, you know, it's more loneliness, more stress, more isolation, more mental health concerns.
直到最近，世界卫生组织才宣布孤独基本上是一种流行病，基本上是一种紧迫的健康威胁。这不仅是个人的问题，也是集体的问题。从我刚才谈到的数据中跳出来的一个非常奇怪的趋势是，许多美国人，特别是这项研究进行的地方，在社交时间方面已经用宠物取代了人。2003年，典型的女性宠物主人花在与人类社交上的时间要比
And it's only recently that the World Health Organization, you know, declared loneliness, basically an epidemic, basically a pressing health threat. It's not just a personal problem, it's a collective problem. One of the really curious trends to jump out of that data that I was talking about before is that a lot of Americans in particular, that's where the study was conducted, have traded people for pets when it comes to social time. In 2003, the typical female pet owner spent much more time socializing with humans. than playing with her cat or her dog. And by 2022, this is flipped.
陪猫或狗玩的时间多得多。到2022年，这种情况发生了翻转。拥有宠物的普通女性现在花在积极与宠物互动上的时间，比她花在与人类面对面闲逛上的时间还要多。问题是。宠物能提供什么其他人可能并不总是能提供的？玩乐，比如一个不断愿意陪伴你闲逛、和你一起获得乐趣的伙伴。而且，你知道的，显然它们不会对我们说话。这不一样。但也许这正是我们所追求的。
The average woman with a pet now spends more time actively engaged with her pet than she spends hanging out face to face with humans. Here's the thing. What does a pet have to offer that may not always be on the table with others? Play, like a constantly willing companion to hang out with, to have fun with. And, you know, obviously they can't talk to us. It's not the same. But maybe that's what we're kind of after.
只是多一点乐趣。我们还必须讨论我们停止为玩乐保留指定时间和空间的更深层的心理原因。我之前谈到过，随着我们年龄的增长，关于我们应该如何行为的期望也在改变。我们的行为受到更密切的审视。犯错的空间更小了。人们希望我们成熟、严肃和负责任。
is just a bit more fun. We also need to talk about some of the more psychological reasons we've stopped having designated time and space for play. I spoke about it before, but the older we get, the expectations around how we should behave change. Our behaviour is more closely scrutinised. There's less room for mistakes. People want us to be mature and serious and responsible.
否则，他们可能会说我们患有彼得潘综合征，或者他们可能会说我们很幼稚。但我们越是隐藏这样一个事实，即我们每个人都有纯粹为了好玩而进行玩乐的内在需求，通过自我管束和条件反射，它就会变成一种习惯，直到即使我们有了那个机会，我们也无法真正调动那种玩乐精神。我们无法调动那种快乐。它被锁得死死的。而且我认为我们的想象力是一块肌肉，它绝对因为缺乏使用而退化了。我最近经历过这个。太有趣了。我正在和大学的一位老朋友、我以前的一个室友叙旧。我们已经几个月没见了，我们在胡闹，我们在大笑。
Otherwise, they might say we have Peter Pan syndrome or they might say that we're childish. But the more we hide the fact that we, each of us have an innate need to just literally have fun, the more of a habit it becomes through self-policing and conditioning until even when we have that opportunity, we can't actually draw on that on that playfulness. We can't draw on that joy. It's so locked away. And I think our imagination is a muscle and it's definitely weakened from a lack of use. I kind of experienced this recently. It so interesting. I was catching up with an old friend from university, one of my old roommates. And we haven't seen each other in months and we're goofing around and we're laughing.
这个女人竟然转过身来。我们在户外。她转过身来，在公共场合、在户外嘘我们。她对我们嘘声相向，还对我们指指点点。这恰好是我这期节目所需要的例子，展示了社会是如何管束我们将我们塑造成严肃之人的。这让我感到相当难过。你知道的，我们是两个显然很高兴见到彼此、充满爱、喜悦和笑声的人。而这却惹恼了她。我有点，你知道的，我不喜欢在公共场合评判别人，但我有点像，哇，也许你已经失去了一点火花。也许你今天过得不好。我不知道。但这确实证明了我自己的观点，对吧？这里发生了一点认知偏差、确认偏差，那就是我们就是不知道该如何像以前那样去享受乐趣。
And this woman literally turned around. We were outdoors. She turned around and she shushed us in public, outside. She shushed us and she tuddled at us. And that was exactly the example I needed for this episode of how society polices us and conditions us into being serious. And it made me quite sad. You know, we were two people who were obviously so excited to see each other, so full of love and delight and laughter. And that was annoying to her. And I kind of, you know, I don't like to judge people in public, but I was a bit like, wow, maybe you've lost your spark a little bit. Maybe you're having a bad day. I don't know. But it kind of proved a point that I had for myself, right? There was a bit of cognitive bias, confirmation bias happening, which is that we just don't know how to have fun the way
我认为尽管如此，尽管我们担心如果我们对朋友说：“嘿，朋友，我想来个成年人玩伴日”，他们可能会觉得：“这真的很奇怪。”而且没有人喜欢被拒绝的感觉。尽管如此，尽管有不这样做的理由，我认为我们必须让这件事发生。在这段简短的广告之后，我想告诉你我们究竟该怎么做，如何将玩乐重新带回我们的社交生活中。2%。这就是有扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
that we used to. I think despite all that and despite our worries that if we were to be like, hey friend, I want to have an adult play date, they might be like, that is really weird. And no one likes the feeling of being rejected. Despite that, despite the reasons not to do it, I think we need to make this happen. And I want to tell you exactly how we can do that, how we can bring play back into our social lives after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when they're is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生具有炎症性。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TW0% 在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TW0% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
好吧，你可以在《回看当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备在某天谈论可卡因，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks.
所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难行易》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候已经做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
因为你觉得在这里活着的时候做一个好人很重要？还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我，基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《知难行易》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free IHeartRadio app.
搜索《知难行易》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律战的序幕，以证明真相。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉尔斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. The Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
女士们先生们，马里科帕郡的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。玩乐比你想象的要科学得多。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Podcasts. Play is a lot more scientific than you might think.
我想我们往往认为这只是为了好玩，但是，你知道的，对一个人来说，好玩可能是连续玩八小时电子游戏，然而，你知道的，对其他人来说，好玩是体力上的，玩乐是具有创造力的，玩乐是充满冒险的。如果你想有更多的成年人玩伴日，如果你想把玩乐作为你生活的核心，正如我认为你应该的那样，甚至包括独自的玩伴日，你需要了解你的玩乐个性。所以这个玩乐个性的概念是由玩乐心理学的祖师爷之一斯图尔特·布朗博士创立的，他接着创立了国家玩乐研究所，这真是一份太酷的工作了。这就像是一个梦想中的职业头衔。但基本上，通过观察儿童、青少年以及更重要的成年人，他开始意识到我们如何享受闲暇时间对我们所有人来说并不相同。
I think we tend to assume it's just having fun, but, you know, for one person, fun might be playing video games for eight hours straight, whereas, you know, for other people it's physical, players, creative, players, adventurous. If you want to have more adult play dates, if you want to center play in your life as I think you should, even doing solo play dates, you need to know your play personality. So this idea of a play personality was created by, like, one of the grandfathers of play psychology, Dr. Stuart Brown, he went on to create the National Institute for Play, which that is such a cool job. That's like a dream job title. But basically by observing children, teenagers, and importantly adults, he began to realize that how we enjoy our downtime is not the same for all of us.
因此，如果你想通过玩乐与别人建立联系，你们的玩乐个性必须在某种程度上保持一致。我们可能拥有八种截然不同的玩乐个性。所以让我们来看看它们，并思考这些中哪一个可能最符合你喜欢如何享受乐趣。所以第一个是收藏家。收藏家玩乐的刺激在于，你知道的，收集物品或体验、小饰品、衣服、葡萄酒、硬币、古董。他们可能更加孤独，但他们真正关注的是，你知道的，建立一个他们可以感到自豪的物品收藏，出去寻找这些东西，寻找这些东西。
So if you want to connect with someone else through play, your play personalities kind of have to be aligned. And there are eight distinct play personalities that we can have. So let's go through them and just think about which of these might relate best to how you like to have fun. So the first one is the collector. The thrill of play for the collector is, you know, collecting objects or experiences, trinkets, clothes, wine, coins, antiques. they might be a lot more solitary, but what they're really focused on is, you know, making a collection of things that they can feel proud of, going out and sourcing these things, finding these things.
因此，如果你想通过玩耍与他人建立联系，你们的玩耍个性必须在一定程度上相契合。我们每个人可以拥有八种不同的玩耍个性。让我们一起来了解它们，并想一想其中哪些最符合你喜欢娱乐的方式。第一种是“收藏家”。对收藏家来说，玩耍的刺激在于收藏物品或经历，比如小饰品、衣服、红酒、硬币、古董。他们可能更喜欢独处，但他们真正关注的是建立一个能让他们感到骄傲的藏品系列，出去寻找并获取这些东西。
And they often have really intense social connections with others who share this passion. Then we have the competitor. Competitors access the euphoria and the joy of play by participating in a competitive game with specific rules. they are not just playing for the sake of playing, they are playing to win. So if you like games that, you know, keep score, if you like games in which you can win, I think that is probably going to be your primary play personality. This is people who really like playing in team sports.
他们通常与有这种共同热情的人有着非常强烈的社会联系。接下来是竞争者。竞争者通过参与具有特定规则的竞技游戏来获得欣快感和游戏的快乐。他们不只是为了玩而玩，他们是为了赢而玩。所以，如果你喜欢那些记分的、能分出胜负的游戏，我想这可能就是你主要的玩耍个性。这类人非常喜欢参加团队运动。
They might like single player video games where they might be like, oh, that wasn't fun unless I got something out of it and the thing I got out of it was success. then we have the creator slash artist play personality and for this person the creator artist the joy is found in just making things and they don't have to be good it could be painting pottery sculpture you know knitting sewing even gardening is also included in this and the thing is is that this creator artist type they might never even show what they've created to the outside world the point for this them is just to make something, to make something maybe beautiful or functional, sometimes like ridiculous, and to make something that they enjoyed the process of making, not just for the
他们可能喜欢单人电子游戏，会觉得“如果没有从中学到什么，那就没意思，而我从中得到的就是成功”。然后是创造者/艺术家型的玩耍个性，对于这类人来说，快乐就在于纯粹地创造事物，而且这些东西不一定非要完美，它可以是绘画、陶艺、雕塑、编织、缝纫，甚至园艺也包括在内。关键是，这种创造者/艺术家类型的人可能永远不会向外界展示他们创造的东西。对他们来说，重点只是去创造某样东西，创造出也许美丽或实用、有时甚至有点荒唐的东西，并且去享受创作的过程，而不仅仅是为了创作。
sake of making. Then we have the director. Directors play by planning. They might enjoy, you know, executing scenes or events. I always think about a film director, obviously. Most people who have this play personality aren't even aware of their motive in playing this way. They just like having the power to make things happen. They like creating things by directing things. They're just kind of like born organizers. They are the party givers. They are the planners of great excursions. They bring people together. They create like really fun events. That's the director. Then we have the explorer, you know, exploring. I think that the, you know, the name kind of says, there's most of it, but it can be physical, like literally, you know, traveling, going on hikes,
接着是导演。导演型的人通过规划来进行玩耍。他们可能会享受策划场景或活动的乐趣。我自然总是会想到电影导演。大多数拥有这种玩耍个性的人甚至都没有意识到自己这样玩的动机。他们只是喜欢掌控一切的力量，喜欢通过执导来创造事物。他们有点像是天生的组织者。他们是派对的举办者，是伟大远足的策划者。他们把人们聚集在一起，创造出非常有趣的活动。这就是导演。然后是探险家，探索嘛，我觉得这个名字已经说明了大部分意思，但它可以是身体上的，比如字面意义上的旅行、徒步、
going on road trips, or it can be emotional, you know, searching for a new feeling or deepening feelings through music, through movement. It might also be through exploration of a new subject. And this is what I found really interesting about this play personality is people who really like, I don't know, getting into a deep dive on Wikipedia or who get really fixated. on one specific subject for a while. That often has a lot of overlap with people who are neurodivergent as well. We have three more to go. We have The Joker.
自驾游，也可以是情感上的，比如通过音乐、动作去寻找一种新的感觉或加深某种感受。它也可能通过对一个新学科的探索来实现。而这正是我发现这种玩耍个性非常有趣的地方，那就是那些真的很喜欢深入研究维基百科，或者在一段时间里对某个特定主题极度着迷的人。这通常与神经多样性（神经发散）人群有很多重叠之处。我们还有最后三种。这就是“小丑”。
The Joker's play always revolves around like some kind of foolishness, like pranks or comedy or stand-up. That's like such a classic form of playfulness. Then we have the kinesthetic player. So these are people who like to move. maybe they even need to move in order to think. They like to naturally push their bodies and feel the result. Obviously, run clubs at the moment are a huge thing.
小丑式的玩耍总是围绕着某种滑稽行为，比如恶作剧、喜剧或单口相声。这绝对是玩耍精神的一种经典形式。接下来是动觉型玩家。这些人喜欢运动，甚至可能需要通过运动来思考。他们喜欢自然地挑战自己的身体并感受效果。显而易见，跑步俱乐部现在非常火爆。
A lot of kinesthetic players are probably really drawn to that. You know, yoga, dance. They just like the openness of it all. You know, competition isn't really the main focus. They just like engaging in play through movement. And finally, we have the storyteller. So imagination is really, the key to the joy that this person gets from play.
很多动觉型玩家可能对这种形式非常着迷。比如瑜伽、舞蹈。他们只是喜欢那种全然的开放感。你知道，比赛其实并不是核心焦点，他们只是喜欢通过运动来参与玩耍。最后，我们要讲的是故事讲述者。对这类人来说，想象力正是他们从玩耍中获得快乐的关键所在。
They might be, you know, novelist always writing stories or watching movies or, you know, writing screenplays or making cartoons. They feel really engaged in stories and they experience the thoughts and the emotions of these characters in the story really intensely. People who are performers are often storytellers. So people who like acting or give them. lectures or poetry or whatever. Normally they have the storyteller play personality. So these are the eight play personalities. And you know what I love about the play personalities? They reveal two
他们可能是小说家，总是在写故事、看电影、写剧本或者制作动画片。他们对故事有着极高的代入感，能强烈地体验到故事中角色的思想和情感。表演者通常就是故事讲述者。所以那些喜欢演戏、做演讲、朗诵诗歌等等的人，通常都具备故事讲述者的玩耍个性。这就是八种玩耍个性。你知道我最喜欢玩耍个性的是什么吗？它们揭示了两个
important aspects of this that we haven't spoken about before. Play is firstly more than we think it is. You know, it can be researching. It can be collecting. It can be daydreaming. It can be, you know, physical movement. It can be exercising. Whatever it is, I think that makes it so much more accessible. it's not just about being silly and chasing each other around. It's quite intellectual and spiritual at times. And secondly, it goes to show that play isn't just social. It's also solo. And it's also parallel.
我们以前没有谈论过的重要方面。首先，玩耍的内涵比我们想象的要丰富得多。它可以是研究，可以是收集，可以是白日梦，可以是身体运动，也可以是锻炼。无论它是什么，我认为这让玩耍变得更容易实现。它不只是傻乎乎地互相追逐。有时它具有相当的智性与精神内涵。其次，这表明玩耍不仅是社交的，也可以是独自进行的，还可以是平行的。
And that last part is so important. Obviously, we're talking about adult play dates. So solo play is kind of on the back burner today. We really want to talk about playing with other people, playing nice with other people. We're going to return to that at a later date. but parallel play is one of my all-time favorite concepts in psychology. It could even be number one, to be honest. I talk about this all the time.
最后这一点非常重要。显然，我们今天讨论的是成年人的“约玩”。所以独处玩耍今天暂且不谈。我们真正想谈的是和别人一起玩，和别人愉快地玩耍。我们日后会再次探讨这个话题。但平行玩耍是我心理学中历久弥新的最爱概念之一。老实说，它甚至能排在第一位。我一直在谈论这个。
I think it has so many positive and hidden applications to our lives and especially to our 20s. So parallel play, we normally only hear it referred to in children, but, you know, who cares? We are all children at heart. It's basically a form of play where we play adjacent to someone else. So we don't try and influence their behavior. We're in the same room, but we're each doing something.
我认为它对我们的生活，尤其是对我们的二十岁，有着非常多积极且隐蔽的应用。所以说到平行玩耍，我们通常只在小孩子身上听到这个词，但是，谁在乎呢？我们每个人内心深处都还是个孩子。这基本上是一种玩耍形式：我们在另一个人旁边玩耍，但并不试图干涉对方的行为。我们在同一个房间里，但各自在做着
that we love. And we're deriving joy from that separately, but in parallel, knowing that the other person is feeling lots of the same glee and fascination and happiness next to you. So you're kind of sharing in the feeling, but doing the activity separately. Parallel play is in my mind. And maybe this is overstating things. Tell me if you think it is. I think it's one of the answers to rising loneliness in our society because it is so low effort. You still get to. to do what you love and you still get to do what you enjoy but you have company. So there are only two rules for parallel play. Firstly, you're both doing something that you enjoy as individuals. And secondly, you're not like completely ignoring each other. So one therapist put it this way.
自己热爱的事情。我们各自从中获得快乐，但又是并行不悖的，你知道另一个人此时此刻正和你一样，身边洋溢着同样的喜悦、着迷与快乐。所以你某种程度上是在分享这种感受，但又各自独立地进行着活动。平行玩耍在我看来——也许这话说得有点夸张，如果你觉得是的话请告诉我——我认为它是解决当今社会日益严重的孤独感的方法之一，因为它所付出的努力太少了。你依然可以做自己热爱的事，依然可以做自己喜欢的事，但同时你拥有陪伴。所以平行玩耍只有两个规则。首先，你们俩作为独立个体都在做自己喜欢的事。其次，你们不是完全无视对方。所以一位治疗师是这样说的：
If one person is, you know, playing really intense immersive video games and it doesn't matter to them whether their partner or their friend is in the room or not, that's not parallel play. It's like more deep than that. You invite a friend. over for a movie and one of you scrapbooks whilst you knit. You know, you're at the beach reading whilst they're building a sandcastle. You're separate, but equally tapped into the same experience, the experience of play and doing it next to each other and still being involved with each other. There are a few other ways that we can really bring that parallel play into our lives, right? Inviting a friend over, like I said, to both do something separately that you were
如果一个人在玩节奏非常激烈、沉浸式的电子游戏，而且不管伴侣或朋友在不在房间里对他们来说都无所谓，那就不叫平行玩耍。它的内涵要更深一些。比如你邀请朋友来家里看电影，你们一个在做手账，另一个在织毛衣。你在海滩上看书，而他们在堆沙堡。你们是独立的，但又同样沉浸在相同的体验中——即玩耍的体验，在彼此身旁做着这件事，并且依然与对方保持着互动。还有其他几种方法可以真正把平行玩耍融入我们的生活中，比如像我刚才说的，邀请朋友来家里，各自做一件
equally engaged in or going in like a pottery class together. Going for a run together is the perfect example of parallel play. Like you are both on your own mission to get the run done and over. Maybe if you enjoy running, it's more enjoyable than that. But you know, you're both doing the same thing, but you are doing it separately. You're not, you know, one of you isn't moving one leg and the other person moving the other. You're enjoying the same experience in each other's presence, but doing it separately, if that makes sense. And it's so amazing how when you start implementing this, you really see your relationships change because so often now,
同样投入的事情，或者一起去上陶艺课。一起去跑步就是平行玩耍的完美例子。你们都在各自努力完成跑步任务。也许如果你喜欢跑步，那它会比这更有趣。但你知道，你们在做同一件事，只是各自独立完成。不是说你们中一个人的两条腿在动，另一个人在动别的。你们在彼此的陪伴下享受着相同的体验，但又是各自独立完成的，如果这好理解的话。真奇妙，当你开始践行这一点时，你会真正看到你的人际关系发生改变，因为现在很多时候，
I think socializing as an adult involves alcohol, involves structure, involves activities done at nighttime. And when we bring in parallel play, it's like we have more room to be creative and actually do something that's going to make us feel good at the end of the day and feel better and feel like our cup is really full. there are a few other ways that we can really bring play back to life. Literally approach hanging out with your friends every time as a play date and call it that. Like say, do you want to come over and do an activity?
我认为成年人的社交往往离不开酒精、流于形式、而且局限于夜间的活动。而当我们引入平行玩耍时，就好像我们有了更多空间去发挥创造力，去真正做一些最终能让我们感觉良好、心情舒畅、并且感觉内心真正充实的事情。还有其他一些方法可以真正让玩耍重获新生。字面意思上，每次和朋友出去玩时，都把它当作一次“约玩”（Playdate）来对待，并且就这样称呼它。比如问：“你想来我家一起做个手工吗？”
Do you want to have a board games night? Do you want to do some arts and crafts? Make that the event. Make that the play date. Be the instigator and make it an experience. This is something that I think all of us need someone like this in our lives, right? the person who is going to be willing to put the extra effort in into making a hangout and activity feel like you are engaged and involved and like there are memories to be made there and
“你想玩桌游之夜吗？想做点艺术手作吗？”把这当作活动本身。把这当作一次约玩。去做那个发起者，把它变成一次体验。我认为我们所有人的生活中都需要这样一个人，对吧？就是那个愿意付出额外努力，让聚会和活动感觉引人入胜、让人参与其中，并且觉得能在其中创造美好回忆的人，
you're really joyful and playing together. I would say devote like a day once a fortnight to a play date and be intentional about it. Make the extra 10% of effort to switch from dinner own drinks to, you know, a movie and a board game night or going to a board game bar. Like, those things exist. They're so fun. Join a social sport team. So me and my friends do this at the moment. And sometimes it's such a, like, such a hassle to get everyone to show up.
让大家真正感受到快乐并一起玩耍。我建议每两周抽一天时间来进行一次约玩，并且要有意识地去做。多付出10%的努力，把“去吃饭喝酒”变成“看电影加桌游之夜”，或者去桌游酒吧。真的有这种地方，而且超级有趣。加入一个社交运动队。我和我的朋友们现在就在这样做。有时候，要让所有人准时出席真的是一件很麻烦的事。
But when you do, it's like, okay, we have this one night a week that we feel obligated to go to, which sometimes is a bit stressful. But when we get there, we know we're going to have fun. And I don't think about work once. and our endorphins, you know, rise and we get a sweat up and we're laughing together. And it not only means that you see people more regularly because you have this thing that you go to together, but you actually are engaged in the experience of doing it with them. And you feel more present, but also more relaxed, if that makes sense.
但当你真正聚在一起时，就会觉得：好吧，我们每周有这样一个晚上必须去打卡，虽然有时候会觉得有点压力。但当我们到达那里时，我们知道我们会玩得很开心。而且我连一次都不会去想工作的事情。我们的内啡肽飙升，开始流汗，大家一起开怀大笑。这不仅意味着你们因为有这样一个共同参与的活动而能更频繁地见面，而且你们真正沉浸在与他们共同经历的体验中。你会感觉自己更加专注，同时也更加放松，如果这说得通的话。
And I think going back to that previous point, because I kind of just hit on it briefly, but I want to go into it further. like I said before, be the instigator. Invite people in. Find community through what you love first. If it's sport, if it's art, people are more likely to show up and do things that they want to do, especially if you make it exciting and especially if you bring community into that process. The other thing that I've been really committed to, and especially on weekends when the weather isn't terrible, is also making it a priority to be outside to kind of move a hangout to somewhere scenic or nature-based. I get it so much easier in summer.
我想回到前面那个观点，因为我刚才只是简要提了一下，但我还想深入探讨。就像我之前说的，做那个发起者。邀请大家加入。首先通过你热爱的事物来寻找社群。无论是运动还是艺术，人们更有可能现身并去做他们想做的事，特别是如果你把活动变得令人兴奋，特别是如果你把社群融入到这个过程中。我一直致力于做的另一件事，尤其是在天气不算太糟糕的周末，是把走到室外作为首要任务，把聚会地点转移到风景优美或大自然的地方。夏天要做到这一点容易得多。
So if you're like in the Northern Hemisphere, congratulations, this is not too hard for you. But even like choosing a physical activity indoors is so much more fun and more enriching. Like especially when that's time in nature, the world is your playground. You get to go out and reconnect with who you are as a human. and get some fresh air and it's just joy experience and a special memory. I was speaking about this to a friend of mine the other day and almost two years ago we went on this hike. Honestly, it was probably three years ago.
所以如果你身处北半球，恭喜你，这对手头的事来说不算太难。但即使是选择在室内进行体育活动，也同样充满乐趣和丰富体验。特别是当这些时间在大自然中度过时，整个世界就是你的游乐场。你可以走出去，重新连接作为人类的自我，呼吸新鲜空气，收获快乐的体验和特别的回忆。前几天我和一个朋友聊起这个，大约两年前我们去进行了一次徒步。说实话，可能已经是三年前了。
We went on this hike together and it was totally out of routine for us. We don't do it that much. And anytime I think about like my core memories and experiences with this person, I couldn't tell you like the last place we got dinner. I couldn't tell you the last meal that we had together. But I always reflect on. this hike and I reflect on how special and meaningful it was. Also, run chores together. I am going to make an argument for the fact that chores are a form of play and you can make them fun and you can make them fun.
我们一起去徒步，这完全打破了我们的常规生活。我们并不常这么做。每当我想起我和这个人之间的核心记忆和经历时，我说不上我们上次去哪吃晚餐。我说不上我们一起吃的上一顿饭是什么。但我总是会回想起这次徒步，回想起它是多么的特别和有意义。还有，一起做家务。我要为“家务也是一种玩耍形式，而且你可以把它变得有趣”这一观点进行辩护。
You can take something that is so adult and serious and often such a time commitment and enjoy it more when you approach it like you are a child and when you approach it by bringing someone along and, you know, chatting with them while you do it, making jokes in the eyes. and taking those everyday experiences and being deliberate about your choice to make them interesting and bringing a new dimension to them. That is a form of play. Farmers markets, great opportunity for this if you live near one. It is going to take you the same amount of time as you go into the grocery store.
你可以把一件如此成年人化、严肃且常常耗时的事情，通过像小孩子一样去对待它、带上某个人一起并在边做边聊、开玩笑的方式，变得更加有趣。把那些日常经历精心地做出有趣的抉择，为它们注入全新的维度。这就是一种玩耍。农夫市集，如果你住在附近的话，这就是个极好的机会。它花掉你的时间和去杂货店是一样的。
And maybe they won't have everything that you want or whatever the problem is. But if you like invite friends and you go and do it, there it is. That's a core memory there. that is a fun memory, that is a playful, joyful, wonderful time that you get to reflect back on together. Also engage in microplay, those small moments of glee, games at the grocery store, in the parking lot, with yourself trying to avoid like the cracks in the road, like making funny voices, literally throwing a ball around at lunch, those micro moments like micro habits build up and accumulate they put you back in touch with your imagination and with your just genuine enjoyment of life.
也许他们不会有你想要的一切，或者不管有什么小问题。但如果你邀请朋友一起去逛，那感觉就完全不同了。那就会变成一份核心记忆，那是一段有趣的回忆，是一段好玩、快乐、美妙的时光，日后你们还可以一起回味。还可以参与微观玩耍，也就是那些微小的快乐时刻，比如在杂货店、停车场的小游戏，自己一个人试着避开路上的裂缝，模仿搞怪的声音，在午餐时随手抛接一个球，这些微小瞬间就像微习惯一样不断累积，让你重新找回想象力，找回对生活纯粹的享受。
And I do think that every small moment where we let ourselves be free and we let ourselves be a kid again and we kind of shirk off the responsibilities of adulthood, make us happier people and greatly reduce our stress as well. I just want to conclude this episode by saying, I get that play doesn't seem important and why we push it down. our lists, but the people around you, when you provide them with the opportunity, they will really go for it. Everybody is really looking for opportunities to engage with people in a more meaningful way. Maybe it's like a hangover from the pandemic. I don't know, but all those things
我的确认为，每一个让我们得以释放、让我们允许自己再次像个孩子一样、并且卸下成年人责任的微小瞬间，都能让我们成为更快乐的人，并极大地减轻我们的压力。我只想在这一集快结束时说：我明白玩耍看起来似乎并不重要，也明白为什么我们会把它排在清单的末尾，但当你给周围的人提供机会时，他们真的会全身心投入。每个人都在寻找机会，以便能以更有意义的方式与人交往。也许这是疫情留下的后遗症？我不知道，但所有这些
that we miss about our childhood selves, our creativity and our appreciation for the small things, even our energy, even our sense of hope, but also the fact that we miss. We're not, the fact that the friendships we made back then were so immediately important and valuable and fun, I think play is truly the answer to that. So however you find it in your life, please find a way to incorporate it, find a way to make it an essential, the same way that you would make exercising an essential or the same way that you would make going to work or going to the doctor an essential. Play is, in my mind, if you cannot tell. One of those, those core self-fulfillment and self-actualization activities that we're neglecting.
我们怀念的童年自我，我们的创造力和对微小事物的欣赏，甚至我们的活力、我们的希望感，还有那个事实——我们怀念的不仅仅是过去，而是我们当年建立的友谊是那么的直接重要、有价值且充满乐趣，我认为玩耍真的是这一切的答案。所以无论你在生活中如何找到它，请找到一种方法将它融入其中，让它成为必不可少的事，就像你把锻炼身体当作必不可少的事一样，或者就像你把上班、看医生当作必不可少的事一样。在我看来，如果你还看不出来的话，玩耍正是那些被我们忽视的核心自我实现与自我超越活动之一。
And although they haven't, I don't know if there's been a study on this, I feel like it's contributing to a lot of the modern day problems that people are trying to find solutions for the fact that we are made to be too serious and too disengaged too early. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. I hope you enjoyed it. I hope you got something out of it. I hope that you are scheduling an adult play date right now. Message your friend, see if you can get into a pottery class,
尽管他们可能还没有——我不知道是否有人对此做过研究，但我觉得这正在导致许多现代问题的出现，人们正试图为这些问题寻找解决方案，而问题的根源就在于我们过早地被迫变得过于严肃和过于疏离。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。希望你们喜欢。希望你们有所收获。希望你现在就在预约成年人的约玩。给你的朋友发个信息，看看能不能一起去上陶艺课，
see if you want to go to the beach this weekend, go and play tennis. I don't care what it is. Make it happen. And thank you for listening along. If you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify. Wherever you are listening right now, it helps the show to grow.
看看这个周末想不想去海滩，去打网球。我不在乎是什么。把它安排上。谢谢你们的收听。如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）、Spotify或你正在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评，这有助于节目的成长。
It helps it reach new people. And it makes me really happy. I read every single one of your reviews. They really do make my day. If you have an episode suggestion, if you have any feedback on this episode, if you are thinking about more ways that we could bring play into your life that I didn't mention, please feel free to DM me at that psychology podcast on Instagram. I'd love to hear from you. And until next time, stay safe, be kind and be gentle to yourself. Please and thank you. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalation. later available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through
它能帮助更多新听众听到这个节目。这也让我感到非常快乐。我阅读你们的每一条评论。它们真的让我的一整天都充满意义。如果你有任何节目建议，对本期节目有任何反馈，或者如果你想到了更多我没有提及的把玩耍融入生活的方法，请随时在Instagram上私信我：@that psychology podcast。我很期待听到你们的声音。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。拜托了，谢谢你们。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时还选择走楼梯的人的比例。稍后推出。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和建立韧性的科学。经历一番
some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same. The same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个……同一个高产骗子约会过时。她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。回顾一个播客。1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家们。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kia Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》（Look Back At It）。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基亚·盖姆斯主持的《艰难成长之路》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都实在不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但你们是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士对话。有多少男人穿着一层铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长之路》。
This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档iHeart播客。人类品质保证。谢谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。